[Music]
foreign
reason that observes to reason that acts
[Music]
the light of mourning decomposes
everything
[Music]
in the midst of life everything revolves
around death
foreign
even if we could turn back we'd probably
never end up back where we started
what we call the present is given shape
by an accumulation of the past
what we seek is some kind of
compensation for what we put up with
what happens when people open their
hearts they get better
foreign
taking crazy things seriously is a
serious waste of time
listen up there's no war that will end
all wars
most everything you think you know about
me is nothing more than memories
memories warm you up from the inside
but they also tear you apart
if you only read the books that everyone
else is reading you can only think what
everyone else is thinking
despite your best efforts people are
going to be hurt when it's time for them
to be hurt
spend your money on the things that
money can buy spend your time on the
things that money can't buy
[Music]
the most important thing we learn in
school is that the most important things
can't be learned in school
foreign
fact may not be truth and truth may not
be factual
[Music]
the human heart is like a night bird
silently waiting for something and when
the time comes it flies straight toward
it
[Music]
Dreams Come From the Past not the future
dreams shouldn't control you you should
control them
[Music]
death is not the opposite of life but a
part of it
[Music]
no matter how far you travel you can
never get away from yourself
life is not like water things in life
don't necessarily flow over the shortest
possible route
I never trust people with no appetite
it's like they're always holding
something back on you
[Music]
I have to get stronger like a stray crew
you can never put it back together like
it was
people are drawn deeper into tragedy not
by their defects but by their virtues
what seems threatening is just the echo
of the fear in my own heart
[Music]
the longer I've lived The more I've lost
what's inside me and ended up empty
sometimes fate is like a small Sandstorm
that keeps changing directions
no one who is good can never be ugly
a little nonsense now and then is
relished by the wisest of men
whatever it is you're seeking won't come
in the form You're Expecting
pain is inevitable suffering is optional
but one thing is certain when you come
out of the storm you won't be the same
person who walked into it
that is what this storm is all about
you can hide memories but you can't
erase the history that produced them
no matter how much suffering you went
through you never wanted to let go of
those memories
[Music]
nobody likes being alone that much I
don't go out of my way to make friends
that's all it just leads to
disappointment
[Music]
even chance meetings are the result of
karma
things in life are Faded by our previous
lives
silence I discover is something you can
actually hear
[Music]
people die all the time life is a lot
more fragile than we think
so you should treat others in a way that
leaves no regrets
[Music]
as we go through life we gradually
discover Who We Are
but the more we discover the more we
lose ourselves
whenever I look at the ocean I always
want to talk to people
but when I'm talking to people I always
want to look at the ocean
it's like Tolstoy said happiness is an
allegory unhappiness a story
[Music]
what I think is this you should give up
looking for lost cats and start
searching for the other half of your
shadow
[Music]
remove everything pointless from an
imperfect life and it would lose even
its imperfection
[Music]
a certain type of perfection can only be
realized through the Limitless
accumulation of the imperfect
foreign
[Music]
but sometimes your smile can be the
source of your joy
walk as if you were kissing the Earth
with your feet
[Music]
people have a hard time letting go of
their suffering out of a fear of the
unknown they prefer suffering that is
familiar
[Music]
we have more possibilities available in
each moment than we realize
say it before you run out of time say it
before it's too late
say what you're feeling
sometimes it's not the people who change
it's the mask that falls off
[Music]
if I have left a wound inside you
it is not just your wound but mine as
well
closing your eyes isn't going to change
anything nothing's going to disappear
just because you can't see it
foreign
if you think of someone long enough
you're sure to meet them again
people's memories are the fuel they burn
to stay alive
[Music]
I can bear any pain as long as it has
meaning
[Music]
people can sleep in the same bed and
still be alone when they close their
eyes
[Music]
chance encounters are what keep us going
people leave strange little memories of
themselves behind when they die
[Music]
loneliness becomes an acid that eats
away at you
everyone may be ordinary but they're not
normal
if a person has few friends it means
that his inner world is too complicated
music brings a warm glow to my vision
thawing mind and muscle from their
endless wintering
whiskey like a beautiful woman demands
appreciation
you gaze first then it's time to drink
there's no such thing as perfect writing
just like there's no such thing as
perfect despair
foreign
[Music]